okay today I'm going to talk to you
about how to find density we're gonna
have a look at two different experiments
how to find the density of a solid and
how to find the density of a liquid so
we're going to start with solids over
here now the first bit of equipment that
you need is a piece of equipment called
a displacement can okay so what a
displacement can is is it's a bit of
equipment that basically it's
essentially just a metal can with a
spout in it that allows water to flow
through the spout I'll show you how to
use it in just a second
you also need a measuring cylinder and
finally the other piece of equipment you
need is an electronic balance to measure
the mass of an object okay so let's
imagine that I was trying to find the
mass sorry the the density of this
particular little plastic cube so I want
to find out how dense this cube is okay
so the first thing I need to do is I
need to measure the mass of the cube so
I'll put it on my electronic balance and
let's imagine that this cube is six
point zero zero grams so it's 6 grams
the next thing I need to do is I need to
figure out the volume of this cube so I
could measure it if it was just a
regular sized cube and find out the
volume that way or if it was an
irregular shape I could use the
displacement can and a measuring
cylinder to find the volume so what I do
is this I fill my displacement can up
with water so the water is just below
the level of the spout what I then do is
I put my cube into the displacement can
full of water now what will happen is
the cube will displace some of the water
ie will cause their water level to rise
and that
water will flow out of here into my
measuring cylinder now let's say for
example the cube displaced 3 centimeters
cubed of water so what I can do now is I
can use this equation for density that
we need to know so it's a simple
calculation my density of this
particular object is the mass which is
right here which is 6 grams and then we
divide it by the volume which is 3
centimeters cubed so as you can see the
density is going to be 6 divided by 3 is
2 and to find the unit I do grams per
centimeter cubed so that's how to find
the density of a solid let's imagine now
we want to find the density of a liquid
let's say some substance similar to
syrup so first thing I do is I get an
electronic balance and I get a measuring
cylinder because I need to find the mass
of the measuring cylinder by itself so
the mass let's say this measure cylinder
let's say is 20 grams what I then need
to do is I need to measure the mass of
the measuring cylinder which now
contains the liquid so I choose a select
volume to put into my measuring cylinder
now what I'm going to select is a
hundred centimeters cubed because that's
a sensible volume to use so I've put my
hundred centimeters cubed in there so
there's my particular liquid it's not
water it's got let's imagine this one
has a mass of a hundred and sixty grams
so that's the measuring cylinder
containing the water so what I need to
do next is I need to find the mass of
the liquid so not water of the liquid
just by itself now to do this I'm going
to take the total mass of the measuring
cylinder containing the liquid and take
away the mass the mass of just the
measuring cylinder so that's a hundred
and sixty takeaway 20 which equals a
hundred and forty grams now that I've
got this mass I can just use my density
calculation so to find the density of
this liquid all I need to do is just
like before my mass of the liquid which
is a hundred and forty grams divided by
the volume of the liquid which is a
hundred centimeters cubed so therefore
my density is 1.4 just do this divided
by this 140 divided 101.4 grams per
centimeter cubed it has a slightly
higher density than water because the
density of pure water is exactly one
gram per centimeter cubed so hopefully
now I've been through this we know how
to find experimentally find the density
of a solid and how to experimentally
find the density of a liquid as long as
we know this really important equation
to remember here thank you